[Musica]
[Applauso]
buongiorno
fatemi fare 14 passi in 14 secondi poi
vi spiego perché 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 14 secondi 14 passi perché
vi spiegherò perché questi 14 passi 14
secondi cos'hanno a che vedere con il
futuro della carne e il futuro del
pianeta
facciamo finta che l'universo invece di
essere nato 13 miliardi e 800 milioni di
anni fa fosse fosse il big bang fosse
accaduto il primo di gennaio dell'anno e
durante l'anno quindi 365 giorni
in realtà faceva facciamo finta che
l'universo tutta la storia dell'universo
fosse in un anno
bene l'essere umano tutta la storia che
conosciamo quindi tutte le persone
importanti della storia
alessandro magno i grandi esploratori
come questo foro colombo grandi come per
esempio giovanna d'arco isabella
cattolica tutti quelli che conosciamo
sono in quest'anno negli ultimi 14
secondi del 31 dicembre per farvi capire
l'insignificanza che abbiamo nella
storia dell'universo in termini di
spazio
la terra a 4 miliardi e mezzo di anni
bene facciamo finta che camminando dal
burkina faso arriviamo in nord italia a
treviso 14 passi sarebbe la storia e
tutte le persone che di cui mai di cui
avete sentito parlare
siamo così piccoli e così importanti
in quest'anno per esempio l'ultima ora è
l'evoluzione dell'uomo negli ultimi 14
secondi tutti i vizi tutti le virtù
tutte le grandi imprese delle persone
della storia e degli spazi abbiamo
spiegato siamo così minuscoli che 25
anni se fosse dal burkina faso fino a
qui benissimo camminando 850 ore
camminando noi saremmo in termini di
spazio 25 anni così se qualcuno è più
grande e così se fossimo 100 anni saremo
così d'accordo siamo così insignificanti
e così importanti allo stesso tempo
questo animale si chiama axolute è una
specie il rischio di estinzione
la biodiversità del pianeta e il rischio
dell'estinzione di varie specie perché
siamo così piccoli però stiamo causando
la sesta in estinzione di massa del
pianeta
in questi 14 passi 14 con di abbiamo
causato
la sesta estinzione di massa della vita
conosciuta nell'universo
noi studiamo animali incredibili come
l'adc slot quando era professore in
bioingegneria negli ultimi anni prima di
lanciare questa startup che si occupa
del futuro della carne vi spiego come
passato da la bioingegneria dove
costruivamo dei reni per esempio il
laboratorio altri laboratorio nel mio
laboratorio dove lavoravo costruiamo per
esempio delle orecchie artificiali un
giorno costruito un orecchio come una
bio stampante che una tecnica molto
avanzata e gli amici cometto giuseppe
questo mi fa schifo questo sembra un
orecchio reale ha detto se fa schifo
vuol dire che fa bene se fa schifo vuol
dire che sembrano vecchio reale detto
perché non possiamo costruire invece di
un orecchio artificiale perché non
possiamo creare noi che siamo i migliori
del mondo
gli ingegneri i tessuti a costruire i
tessuti e organi perché non creiamo
qualcosa simile la carne perché non
facciamo qualcosa che abbia l'impatto
per essere ricordati nella storia per
cercare di contribuire contro il cambio
climatico sono così piccoli per possiamo
fare qualcosa ognuno di noi studiamo
come è fatta interamente la carne e
studiamo qual è l'impatto
adesso vi spiegherò perché
il futuro del cibo il futuro della carne
il futuro del pianeta sono così uniti
l'allevamento utilizza la 83 per cento
di tutto il terreno arabile mondiale ma
nella dieta umana anche se usiamo 83 per
cento delle terre coltivabili per
l'allevamento dall'allevamento otteniamo
solo il 18 per cento delle calorie in
media della dieta umana una inefficienza
incredibile per ogni chilo di carne per
esempio di bistecca prepara una bistecca
per esempio che di carne di mucca ci
vogliono 25 kg di mangime per l'animale
e 15.000 litri di acqua ogni chilo di
carne di mucca che mangiamo
l'effetto serra associato
all'allevamento l'effetto indiretto e
diretto l'allevamento è 14 e mezzo per
cento di tutti e tutte l'effetto serra e
causato dall'uomo ed è superiore a
l'effetto delle navi degli aerei delle
motociclette auto tutte insieme fanno
che viene un 13 per cento o meno
dell'effetto della carne sul pianeta
bisogna avevano capire quali sono le
cose che impattano di più e avere una
prospettiva globale è un momento
perfetto per spingere e per creare
un'alternativa non vogliamo convincere
da un giorno all'altro tutti diciamo a
convincere obbligare a lasciare la carne
ma almeno capire qual è l'impatto
cercare di creare qualcosa che è un
alternativa è il momento adatto perché i
governi stanno cercando una maniera più
responsabile più efficiente di
utilizzare le risorse che hanno in mano
per esempio il governo della cina
le aziende e le aziende di carne sun
cercando di entrare in questo mercato
perché i governi hanno bisogno e il
mercato lo sta chiedendo quindi le
persone nel supermercato e nei burger
king e mcdonald's stanno cercando
alternative
alcuni lo fanno per il colesterolo altri
lo fanno perché per gli antibiotici
nell'allenamento altri lo fanno per gli
estrogeni
ognuna ha la sua ragione altri lo fanno
per ovviamente elettrica animale e altri
per evitare l'impatto del pianeta che
possono causare in questi ultimi anni
questi ultimi anni che sarebbero più o
meno mezzo centimetro dal burkina faso
fino a qui nella storia del pianeta
terra
abbiamo la cina ha chiesto il ministro
della salute di dimezzare i consumi di
carne prima del 2030 2030 sembra lontano
sono dieci anni tutte le aziende
prima la cena poi tutte le altre aziende
americane come tyson foods scarpis sono
lanciate a investire in questo settore
perché se i governi lo chiedono è se la
classe media soprattutto quella cinese
sta chiedendo di consumer a consumare
più carne e l'aumento globale della
carne di un 5 per cento annuale
ci vuole un'alternativa in europa ci
siamo accorti nel 2018 che c'era un
aumento degli ultimi cinque anni del
quattrocento 51 per cento di richiesta
di alternative alla carne nei
supermercati e nei ristoranti e nei
nell'ultimo anno l'ultima ai più quindi
l'ultima uscita in borsa sul nasdaq
la più importante gli ultimi dieci anni
è stata quella di b o smith dopo quella
di yahoo
per capire che passiamo da un tech più
associato a internet che pensavamo fosse
il futuro per sempre ma adesso il foot è
che così di moda che l'ipad più
importante degli ultimi dieci anni è
quella di bio mito un hamburger vegetale
lo stiamo parlando di convincere io a
voi che dovete lasciare la carne ma
stiamo parlando che economicamente
c'è una richiesta dei governi in una
richiesta delle aziende e le persone non
stanno chiedendo quindi c'è un cambio
velocissimo
secondo ubs per esempio la carne
vegetale del sostituto della carne
stanno crescendo come un 28 per cento
annuale il tasso di crescita che è il
doppio quasi dell'online fu delivery in
termini di crash into di crescita annua
e del farm infor po in giro bene
esistono due filoni la carne coltivata
fatta con cellule laboratorio non è
commercializzabile ancora in nessuna
parte del mondo
non si può trovare nei supermercati nei
ristoranti si potrà trovare fra qualche
anno è autentica nel senso che ci sono
cellule animali in laboratorio ma i
tempi i costi di fabbricazione sono
molto molto poco efficienti poi c'è la
carne vegetale dove i tempi i costi di
fabbricazione sono già ottimi ma non si
riesce a ottenere bene a parte la carne
processata come gli hamburger e polpette
e
salsicce per esempio non si riesce a
tenere la cosa simile una carne team
rosa e lì è dove stiamo lavorando noi
con la start up per cercare di unire il
sapore di quello che si ottiene adesso
con la carne per esempio gli hamburger
vegetali che sanno di carne questi nuovi
che si sono stati lanciati negli ultimi
anni alla consistenza fibrosa che si
attende a tecniche tradizionali che per
adesso non permettono che il prodotto
abbia un sapore di carne e l'apparenza
simile a quella che si può ottenere con
carne in laboratorio con cellule
quindi cerchiamo di unire questo e
adesso offriamo di fare diversi
prototipi i primi non assomigliano pezzi
di carne ma hanno già la consistenza
fibrosa di un pezzo di carne essendo
composti solo da ingredienti vegetali
possiamo creare una cosa che più
proteico che non ami colesterolo che non
antibiotici ovviamente possiamo creare
qualcosa nei prossimi anni che davvero
sia un'alternativa non sarà facile
creare un'alternativa alla fiorentina
non è quello è l'obiettivo
l'obiettivo è quello di cercare di
creare un'alternativa sempre migliore e
che assomigli sempre di più un pezzo di
carne che non solo abbia come adesso la
solo la consistenza fibrosa ma che abbia
anche una struttura dove si può unire il
muscolo il grasso nello stesso prodotto
d'accordo quindi se lo facciamo con la
stampante 3d lo facciamo su piccola
scala
abbiamo un impatto globale l'importante
però limitato perché ci occupiamo di
cibo personalizzato che possiamo creare
questa stampante 3d di qualità
nell'educazione perché i ristoranti gli
studenti possono creare cose nuove
però quando passiamo alla scalabilità
produciamo non con una stampante ma come
la macchina grande una alternativa alla
carne
allora sì possiamo combattere il cambio
climatico davvero i progetti a futuro
sono ancora più interessanti perché non
è solo questione di creare un
alternativa alla carne perché nei paesi
occidentali mangiamo quattro volte più
proteine del necessario ma le necessità
reali sono per esempio nel futuro
utilizzare la biodiversità
dell'agricoltura che abbiamo ed evitare
che si perdano le coltivazioni di cuba
al di alcuni
di questi semi di alcuni di questi tipi
di agricoltura che abbiamo perso per
esempio stiamo parlando con grandi
organizzazioni per cercare di evitare le
zone rurali del pianeta nel nei prossimi
anni per cercare di portare questa
tecnologia su grande scala dove si
possono utilizzare il l'agricoltura
locale d'accordo e abbiamo parlato del
parlamento europeo nell'onu con le
agenzie spaziali per creare nello spazio
è qualcosa che abbia la consistenza
fibrose non solo cibo liofilizzato e con
grandi chef stellati per creare qualcosa
di nuovo e non sono un'alternativa la
carne e adesso all'ultimo messaggio che
volevo dare che siamo così piccoli nella
storia dell'universo ma così importanti
se ci svegliamo la mattina e andiamo al
lavoro e pensiamo che ci svegliamo per
cambiare qualcosa nel mondo abbiamo una
forza in più che ci spinge molto di più
se ci svegliamo la mattina e sappiamo
che non abbiamo la passione per quello
che facciamo e non stiamo cercando non
stiamo cambiando il mondo
nel nostro piccolo l'accordo quindi
ognuno secondo me deve trovare la sua
passione e deve svegliarsi la mattina
cercando di amare non odiare creare e
non distruggere e ammirare e non
disprezzare e soprattutto negli ultimi
anni dove la frustrazione le ansietà
creano problemi così gravi quindi perché
non essere ricordati come la prima
generazione nella storia nella prima
generazione di esseri umani che ha fatto
qualcosa contro cambio climatico adesso
che abbiamo allo stesso tempo la
tecnologia e l'informazione siamo
fortunati e la prima volta siamo la
prima generazione che ha la tecnologia
in mano per cambiare le cose davvero e
l'informazione possiamo avere in mano
con internet con le enciclopedie con i
grandi esperti mondiali sappiamo come
farlo è il momento di farlo
io ho scelto di essere ricordato e
vorrei che tutti quanti pensassimo di
cercare di essere ricordati per fare
fatto cose di buono per il pianeta
d anche se siamo così piccoli nella
storia di aver fatto la cosa di grande
grazie
[Applauso]